[Music]
it's
okay so this side is's
pushing you always get him
turning and this one's cool because you
have two inward
Spirals and then after that we have two
hour spirals Okay so outside the
arm just like solto
kaien you just have to wait for the
other
one and then here's your two outward
spirals so deviate under
[Music]
w
okay try it
again okay so I deviate
one look he's in the technique you see
you hear C hole right
here there go go here here
now
DV is
in
that DV
there okay got that okay let's try it
again technique like this a lot of theid
get scared they can't figure out what
they're doing and they start to uh pull
back their tanden from the Keyon
remembering key after the tanden form
he's going to let me move his tanden
around but the scared do kid is always
going to go nope nope okay uh so it's
not uncommon so you could go your here
like that you see he's not going to go
under turn this way stay there you see
he's starting to loosen the the one
connection point you see his grip okay
so you'll come around and you'll grab
here you see now and now even if he lets
go let go you still have
it you don't want to be feeling that
okay so I comeing around here and he's
not turning under you just grab it right
here the other one you look for around
the sca that starts to let go is the
back hand you see you have the front
hand then you have your boom you're ATT
taming coming around he let's
go and down
okay B because in essence he's
countering the technique you see the
technique I guess we're doing Gaza
that we don't do that in
key your option when you're afraid is to
go slow and keep
connection
not to counter the technique you kind go
slow that's how fast or how hard you're
going to push but you keep connection
with your own
Center and the manipulation of that
Center by
nogget okay here we
go think about it okay so he's going to
go forward you see how his arm stays
long
don't put it back underneath his feet so
not
here here okay stand
up you get
it so feel instead the energy his
centrifical energy
who there's almost like one rotation
around that P you see did to C you
hole
not everything
here and not two moves one two now one
hand is on the falling top
if you pay
attention when I throw
him there we go this bottom arm I'm
displacing his base ever so
slight look for
[Applause]
that okay try it again okay so you
usually you'll have your inertial injury
cuz he's right we go slow he's going
backwards you see that he's going
backwards you see that
but he would be going forward and it's
right here
okay so the less inertia you have the
more mechanical engines you have okay
see how I use the legs with my arm okay
so same same thing I'm here and I
use my arm on the
leg
all that gets lighter if you combine it
here
so okay try it again I thought the arm
one was cool okay but if you can't if
you can't rock it when you come around
here your Bas is right there okay so you
can do that one to side coming around
all the row
boom
around